[музика]
Володимир Олександрович Зеленський
звертаюсь до вас тут Тому що Ну от це
місто президента в парламенті але вас
тут нема ви взагалі тут буваєте рідко А
в мене є зараз до вас питання чи ви
вважаєте
чеснию просто нормальне те що Кабінет
Міністрів України призначив довічну
стипендію вашому батьку Олександру
семеновичу
зеленському ви вважаєте це нормально
Ви самі злидені в цій державі на
військових не вистачає виплата на дитину
860 грн на
місяць що отримують залізничники лікарі
освітяни не треба
розповідати і довічна стипендія вашому
батьку на День вчителя А як там про
інших вчителів я хотів вам це поставити
питання в очі але вас нема але дуже хочу
почути вашу відповідь як там кінець
епохи біднист